the former president of the United
States Donald Trump was arrested and
perp walked yesterday
in New York City police custody with no
handcuffs and reportedly no mug shot and
pleaded guilty sorry pleaded not guilty
what a Freudian slip pleaded not guilty
to 34 different felonies we will talk
about the alleged crimes we will talk
about the potential penalties we will go
to the attorney post arrest press
conference Trump's Mar-A-Lago speech
we're going to cover everything
but it's important to sit back for a
moment and understand
it was almost surreal yesterday as we
did many many many many many many hours
of live streams covering all of this the
former president arrested and it may
only be the first of many arrests a
report starting to swirl about a
possible second arrest in Georgia later
this month we still have questions about
the federal case but let's not get to
that yet Donald Trump on his way to the
courthouse posting on Truth social truth
essential quote heading to lower
Manhattan the courthouse
seems so surreal wow they are going to
arrest me can't believe this is
happening in America
Maga and listen I agree it was surreal
to so many of us who were watching uh
nearly half a million of you stopped by
the live stream where we covered Trump's
uh path down to the courthouse in lower
Manhattan and eventual booking in the
entire thing it truly was surreal we
have video here of Donald Trump's
motorcade arriving at the courthouse
Trump getting out and sort of uh
lumbering waving at one point to the
dozens of supporters that showed up and
then lumbering surrounded by Secret
Service into the courthouse there was
this very unusual situation where there
was a ring of secret service around
Trump and also NYPD and of course New
York uh Courthouse Court officers kind
of managing the uh situation as they as
they often do we then were able to see
video from the 15th floor of Donald
Trump entering the actual uh courtroom
maybe the first time in decades that
Donald Trump actually had to hold the
door for himself and here you see all of
these different rings of security uh
let's take a look at this video
there is Trump entering looking dejected
quite frankly
very briefly there as you see
going into the courtroom these were very
very brief moments Trump then spending
about an hour in the arraignment which
is very unusual legal experts weighing
in that these arraignments even when
there are 34 counts like this usually
there is a a waving of the full reading
of all of these counts this took nearly
an hour and that is not typical for such
an arraignment and we still don't know
exactly what took so long we do know
that the judge did admonish everyone
that he wants uh he I'm sort of
paraphrasing here but that the judge
would like there not to be public
commentary that turns up the heat on
this entire thing that didn't last very
long that I can assure you and then
about an hour later video so let's see
the video going in was 2 28 p.m the
video coming out was 3 24 p.m so almost
a full hour to the minute here is Donald
Trump leaving the courtroom and again a
very very very brief sighting of trump
they're about to come out of the
courtroom let's listen into the Hall
[Music]
s
okay
[Music]
And Then There Goes Trump and you see
his lawyer Joe takapina who previously
said Trump did commit a crime when he
was interviewed about this on TV years
ago okay so the judge warning everybody
refrain from statements and social media
posts that could foment unrest and all
of this after there were many messages
critical of the prosecutor before those
certainly didn't stop after and we are
going to get to that so an incredible
moment I mean this really is a historic
moment uh it is unusual it is unique it
is different and then now the focus
starts to become
what is actually going to happen with
these cases what are we actually going
to see happen what are the charges and
what is the maximum possible sentence
let's talk about that next
one of our sponsors today is fume not
everything in a bad habit is wrong so
instead of a drastic uncomfortable
change why not just remove the bad part
from your habit fume is an Innovative
award-winning device that does exactly
that fume is not electronic there's no
Vapor or harmful chemicals fume is just
a delicious flavored air that makes
replacing your bad habit easy your fume
comes with an adjustable airflow dial
and is designed with movable Parts which
is great for fidgeting which can be
great for people breaking bad habits
look at what people online are saying
they weren't sure what to expect but
ended up loving the taste and the feel
stopping is something lots of people put
off because it's difficult to do but
switching to fume is easy and enjoyable
there's no reason that you can't be the
next fume success story head on over to
try fumed dot com and use the code
Pacman to save 10 percent when you get
the journey pack which comes with the
device and three flavors the link is
down below